back to Cleveland and this has huge  selection of the starting lineup moments  ago  [Music]  [Applause]  the kid from Akron has come home the  Cavaliers are NBA champions and the  impossible dream come true  clear dad this is for you  [Applause]  [Music]  I know that my boy said my platform had  to be used for more than just sports as  LeBron James Family Foundation to be  able to do this and the families to  allow us to be in your kids lives and be  able to try to make a difference it  means so much  by me being able to put something like  this together I want people to know that  these kids should still have the same  opportunity as everyone else  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]